tonight we want to introduce you to the
woman nancy pelosi is blaming
erica cayas owns the now famous salon in
san francisco and she joins us tonight
erica thanks so much for coming on
thank you so much for having me nancy
pelosi claims
on camera that you orchestrated a quote
set up to entrap her
into getting her hair blown out without
a mask did you
no absolutely not
how would you have done that i mean can
you prove that this wasn't a diabolical
setup designed to bring down the speaker
of the house by blow drying her hair
i she had called the stylist and or her
assistant did and made the appointment
so yes the appointment was already
booked so there's no way i could have
set that up
and i've had a camera system in there
for five years i mean i didn't
go in there and turn cameras on as soon
as she walked in to set her up
so that's absolutely false so pelosi
says that
salons in san francisco and of course
she lives there and she is the most
powerful democratic legislator in the
world but she says she understood that
the
restrictions allowed a one-on-one
appointment in salons
what do you make of that i
heard that and i thought to myself well
as a hair stylist
i see clients one-on-one so
that would mean i would be open right
yes yes bart start starting to laugh yes
that it would mean that are you are you
open no
what is that doing to you in your
business
um for the past six months we've i mean
we're pretty much
done i mean we've lost
um at least 60 percent of our clients
um i've lost the majority of my staff
um so you know six months is a long time
to be closed down
yeah no it's i mean it's it's too long
so your business has been destroyed by
this
how do you how do you feel about seeing
the most powerful woman in america come
into your salon in violation of the
rules she supports
get caught and then blame you for it
to be honest it was more hurtful
she's been coming in for quite a while
and
just to see her come in and especially
not wearing the mask that's what really
got to me but
you know this isn't even political i
mean she's been coming in there it's the
fact that she actually came
in and
didn't have a mask on and i just thought
about you know my staff and people
not being able to work and make money
and provide for their families and
if she's in there comfortably without a
mask and feeling safe then why
are we shut down why am i not able to
have clients come in
so it's been it's been hard
you're not making a political point
you're making a human point rooted in
common sense and what do you think i
don't know what the answer is what do
you think the answer is why can't
if nancy pelosi feels comfortable using
your salon why can't civilians use it
exactly and i'll be honest in our area
in san francisco i mean we're obviously
the last
um county or city to uh not open
um we've been trying to figure that out
we've been
asking ourselves these questions for six
months i mean
for the past actually four months um
of why we are not reopened um
and that's kind of a good question we
again don't know huh
what are you going to do are you going
to stay in the city do you think in san
francisco
um i don't think so i
um the hard part of all this is that i
have been
in that community for 12 years and
since this happened i have received
nothing but hate
text messages death threats they are
going to burn my hair salon down
my yelp page is just unbelievable um
with bad reviews um
it's just um it's sad that my community
um
is pulling this when they're saying that
i threw her under the bus when
i i didn't um so that's hurtful but i
think yeah i think i'm pretty much done
there
so yeah well i think that's one of the
most heartbreaking stories i've heard in
a long time
a long time and i just want to restate
for the people who are
hating you for telling the truth i don't
consider this political you don't seem
like a political person
and i'm just sorry this is happening to
you erica thank you for coming on
tonight
thank you